lilia blaise bonjour lydia vous êtes à
tunis comment la guerre est-elle vécue
sur place et quels en sont les premiers
effets
alors les tunisiens ont beaucoup suivi
l'actualité en ukraine dès les premiers
jours de l'intervention russe notamment
avec la question du rapatriement des
étudiants tunisiens en ukraine puisque
plusieurs centaines d'étudiants
tunisiens suivent des cursus soit de
médecine soit d'études d'ingénieur ils
ont été rapatriés à 75% d'entre eux
cette semaine via la roumanie et la
pologne et puis sur le plan diplomatique
on peut voir que la tunisie s'est
positionné avec 141 autres pays en
faveur de la résolution présentée aux
nations unies qui condamne
l'intervention russe mais elle garde
elle joue un peu un rôle d'équilibristes
1 face à la russie puisqu'elle a
toujours eu des bonnes relations avec le
pays on avait pu voir l'année dernière
il y avait eu le lancement du premier
satellite tunisien en russie et
lll garde position assez neutre puisque
le ministre des affaires étrangères
tunisien a reçu cette semaine le nouvel
ambassadeur russe à tunis elle il ya
plus globalement au delà de la tunisie
cette crise a un impact économique pour
tout le maghreb
alors oui en tunisie on peut voir que ça
se ressent dans les prix comme l'a dit
votre sujet tout à l'heure la tunisie
subit de plein fouet la hausse du prix
du carburant déjà elle en est déjà à sa
deuxième augmentation en moins d'un mois
et puis la tunisie est très dépendante
des importations russes et ukrainiennes
sur le blé la tunisie importe près de
50% de sa production en céréales et donc
le prix des céréales et du blé va aussi
avoir un impact dans un pays qui
traverse déjà une très grande crise
économique
par contre on peut voir dans le reste du
maghreb que certains pays se positionne
sur le plan économique notamment
l'algérie qui fournit 12 % delà du gaz
que consomment les européens et qui
pourrait augmenter 7
cette livraison aux pays européens face
à aux sanctions envers la russie alors
l'algérie est un peu aussi un prise dans
l'étau de ce jeu d'équilibré avec moscou
puisque c'est aussi un partenaire elle a
par exemple elle s'est abstenue de voter
la résolution aux nations unies mais il
y a des demandes côté européen notamment
de l'italie à ce que l'algérie augmente
sa production en gaz merci beaucoup pour
ces informations explications lilia
blaise